THROUGH OCCUPIED UKRAINIAN
TERRITORY.
CNN'S BEN WEDEMAN HAS OUR REPORT
FROM THE WAR ZONE.
>> Reporter: AT 3 YEARS OLD,
IVAN DOESN'T KNOW WAR RAGES
AROUND HIM.
"HE DOESN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND IT
YET, "SAYS HIS FATHER IGOR."
WE TRY TO EXPLAIN BOOM BOOM,
IT'S ONLY LOUD CAR PASSING BY.
IVAN'S MOTHER SENYA SHOWS WHERE
THEY LIVE.
NEIGHBORS WHO LEFT THE CITY OF
SLOVYANSK LET THEM MOVE INTO
THEIR GROUND FLOOR APARTMENT
BECAUSE IT'S SAFER.
THE HALLWAY IS FULL OF BOTTLED
WATER.
THE BATHTUB IS FULL THERE HAS
BEEN NO RUNNING WATER HERE FOR
WEEKS.
AS THE AIR RAID SIREN BLARES,
THOSE WHO REMAIN BEHIND WAIT FOR
FOOD SUPPLIES AT A DISTRIBUTION
CENTER.
"WE'RE STAYING," SAYS ZENAIDA.
MY NEIGHBOR HAS A WELL.
HAVE I DOGS AND TWO CATS.
MY HUSBAND HAS DIABETES.
64-YEAR-OLD NIKOLAI SHRUGS OFF
THE DANGER OF STAYING PUT.
"WHERE CAN I GO IF THEY BOMB
EVERYWHERE," HE ASKS ME.
"YOU CAN'T ESCAPE YOUR FATE."
SHE FLED HER VILLAGE NEARBY ON
THE FRONT LINES.
"IT WAS VERY HARD THERE," SHE
SAYS.
"THERE WAS A LOT OF SHELLING.
HALF THE VILLAGE DISAPPEARED.
HER SON-IN-LAW AND HER DAUGHTER
ARE TAKING HER AWAY.
EVERY DAY PEOPLE GATHER FOR
BUSES OUT OF SLOVYANSK.
THE WAR NOW INTO ITS FOURTH
MONTH HAS SEEN MILLIONS FLEE
THEIR HOMES.
WITH NO END IN SIGHT, A SENSE OF
RESIGNATION AND EXHAUSTION HAS
SET IN.
SOME WHO LEAVE MAY NEVER RETURN.
KATYA'S MOTHER AND FATHER HAVE
COME TO SAY GOODBYE.
>> ACTUALLY, I DIDN'T PLAN TO
LEAVE, BUT I DECIDED TO LEAVE
BECAUSE THE SITUATION IS GETTING
MORE AND MORE DANGEROUS.
>> Reporter: